hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk more about dark season 3.
they updated the official dark website
with a modified version of the painting
that adam has hanging in the sick mundus
lair
that brings up some interesting
questions and actually ties in
with an update i wanted to add to my
last season 3 theories video
also they added the phrase the end is
the beginning to the home page which
isn't new
but i have been thinking about it and
want to discuss it before we get going
though this video will contain spoilers
if you're not into that sort of thing or
aren't caught up through the end of
season 2
then this video won't be something
you're gonna want to watch i will
mention spoilery photos from behind the
scenes of filming season 3 that are out
there
and there was a bit of confirmation
information that leaked out in relation
to the website update but i won't
mention that until the very end
netflix has posted an official
description for season 3 since i last
made a video
it reads in the third and final season
dark
reaches its mind-bending conclusion
moving beyond the concept of space and
time
upon arrival in a new world jonas tries
to make sense of what this rendition of
vindin means for his own
fate while the ones left behind in the
other world
are left on a quest to break the loop
that now not only bends
time but also space two worlds light and
dark
and in the center a tragic love story of
epic proportions
this isn't giving a lot away it lines up
with our expectations
that jonas will spend time in the
alternate world where he presumably
traveled with alt martha at the end of
season 2.
the ones who are left behind most likely
refers to the group of survivors in the
bunker
we know that claudio will be
experimenting with the god particle
and that noah and elizabeth will get
together with the latter giving birth to
her own mother
charlotte it's interesting how they
emphasize the epic love story at the
center of things
i'm reminded of a long form interview i
watched with the showrunners last year
where they brought that
up it's funny because as a viewer i
spent so much time trying to figure out
how everything works that i forget that
the star-crossed relationship between
jonas and marta is foundational to the
story they're telling us
the last bit two worlds light and dark
is a perfect transition into the
painting in the background of the
official website
the original piece is the one we've seen
under the church in adam's
lair it's named the fall of the damned
or
the fall of the rebel angels and it was
painted by
peter paul rubens rubens was an
influential flemish painter
from the baroque movement it's a 17th
century
religious painting that depicts the
archangel michael expelling lucifer and
the rebel angels from heaven we see the
archangel at the top
in the light section of the painting
that represents heaven and see the
angels falling towards the dark
as they fall we see their flesh being
torn away by demonic looking creatures
the version of the painting on the
website has several additions related to
the series
in the middle we see jonas in a
radiation suit
these suits are connected to the god
particle time machine in the power plant
so it seems likely that we will see him
visit that
in season three above him we see a
pregnant woman in white
the first guess of who this was was
ennis conwald because there's a
resemblance
she is jonas's grandmother we know that
before she adopted mikhail
she had a child of her own that died at
a very young age
we don't really know the details about
that which leaves some fans wondering if
there's more
to be learned there the other popular
idea of who this might be
is related to a behind-the-scenes photo
that the actor who plays celia
posted and then deleted from her
instagram it's pretty hard not to make a
connection here but we don't know much
about the photo itself
in the reddit post i saw there was an
explanation that the actor had removed
the photo
and there was a related shot of lisa
bakari who plays alt marta
that might be on the same couch
indicating that it came from the set
i don't know i always imagined celia
would be connected in some way or the
other but i guess because of the age we
meet her
at i assumed it would be as someone's
child rather than a parent
next we have what looks like an
alt-world tan house to me he's a
character we know wears glasses
and the device he's with looks like it's
time travel machine related
the only problem is that in prime linden
he has dark hair
as a young man but so far the strategy
appears to be
to mark the alt-world versions with
something to set them apart
if this is ton house it raises a lot of
questions about the evolution of the
time machines
but doesn't provide any answers there is
a spherical object involved which brings
alt marta's device to mind but we'll
have to wait and see what's going on
here
from what we see we can't really deduce
what stage of the development of the
machines this would be
below him there's another pregnant woman
whose face is obscured completely this
could literally be anybody at this point
as there's nothing that's recognizable
as far as i can tell
not far from her we have marta and the
yellow raincoat what stands out most
about her
image is that she's definitely in the
dark portion of the
painting but not necessarily in the pit
of hell visually she's closer to the
dark elements
sort of on the border while jonas above
her is closer to the light elements
this may be indicating that venden prime
is the light world from the season 3
description
which would make sense since that's
where the story started
beyond that you can't make out much
about her other than she looks
distressed
next the new character trio is on the
bottom left of the painting and they
look like they're firmly in the pit of
hell they don't look out of place there
or
in any way distressed about it i
wouldn't say this does much in the way
of solving the mystery of who this
character
is i still believe it's the same person
at three different points in their life
working together and if anything this
just reinforces that they're probably a
dark force
that you wouldn't want to come in
contact with above them is the character
from the season 3 data announcement
trailer who's wearing the pink jacket
and beating someone with a rock
this was something that i wanted to
update from my last video
because reddit discovered that her name
tag had been digitally
changed to read helene albert there was
a theory based on one of the behind the
scenes photos that she was katarina's
mother which i wasn't sold on initially
part of where that skepticism came from
was her name being named helene wolfe
so learning that they went back and
changed it is a pretty big deal
based on in-world documents we know that
katarina's maiden name was albert
this connects her to the character who
aegon visited about the sheep dying his
name was listed in the credits as
heremon
albert so it's been assumed that he's
katarina's father
changing the name tag that's something
that had to happen for a reason
and the only thing that really makes
sense is that this woman is katarina's
mother
who she's hitting with the rock and why
she's important enough to be included in
this painting is still a mystery though
the one low-key addition to this is an
edit of a couple having sex right in the
middle
the woman appears to have dark hair with
bangs which makes you wonder if it's alt
marta and jonas
but we can't really make out the man so
it's not really clear
it's painted on top of a character that
was in the original
and beyond that i'm not sure what to
make of it the final two additions are
both a little strange
on the left side claudius poodle
gretchen has been added
this seems like a bit of fun more than
anything else but we'll see
above her in heaven we see bowler with
no eye injury there has been some
discussion that this might be stranger
jonas based on the images we've seen of
him in the past but i don't see it
there's this behind the scene shot of
roller with a beard that looks like a
closer match to me
does that mean moeller has a big role to
play in season 3
maybe or this could just be the
showrunners continuing to have fun with
the mystery about his eye
that's the last of the added images and
that brings us to the title
when you visit the site you see the word
dark and then the phrase the end is the
beginning
comes across the screen after that it
says discover how everything is the same
but different
the last part refers to the two worlds
light and dark
and jonas making sense of what that all
means the end is the beginning is not a
new phrase in relation to the series but
now that we're at the end it's worth
thinking about
the shorthand ideas he posted everywhere
is that the series will
end right back where it started the
beginning like season 1
episode 1. i get the novelty behind this
and then it might be satisfying because
it would be in line with causal
determinism
i do wonder though how entertaining that
might be considering that not everyone
who watches
and enjoys this show does so because
they like thinking about how time travel
might work in practice
there almost has to be something
character driven behind it it has to
matter that nothing can change and it
should make us feel something or we
should be able to connect to it
in a way that moves us and what does
that look like
the end being the beginning other than
watching michael get ready to hang
himself
does it imply that jonas as adam would
just die
failing to do anything meaningful as a
result of his decades of effort
and don't get me wrong i like a good
tragedy and i do have faith that if they
went this route they would bake in some
sort of catharsis
i'm just curious about what that would
be i'm interested in hearing what you
guys think about that in the comments
i can't imagine a scenario where
whatever adam and or claudia is trying
to do
turns out to be the trigger for what
we've seen so far
but it raises a crazy amount of
questions so let me know what you think
the last thing i want to talk about
before i go is the leaked information
from the website i mentioned
i don't think any of it is really
shocking or even game changing
but i thought i should wait until the
end if you wanted to avoid it
when the site was updated reddit user
t-i-r-a-c-o
posted a javascript file that they found
inside that they noticed that the site
will start displaying information for
characters in two worlds which are
labeled a
and b i doubt this is surprising to
anyone at this point but it is notable
that there are only two
worlds overall this just means when you
look up a character you'll be able to
view information on the original and
alternate versions
the only three names discovered in
relation to world b
were marta magnus and mads without any
additional context as far as i can tell
since they're all names to start with
the letters m a
i'm not reading too much into that
there's obviously other characters that
live in that world there's also a
reference to the year 1888
in world a that shows up in season 3
episode 2.
again we pretty much knew stranger would
end up in that year
but this does seem to confirm it finally
the year 2003 from world a shows up on
jonas's timeline i was hoping that we
would see different years
and this seems to confirm that it's not
really clear jonas may have been born in
2003
if he was only supposed to be 16 when we
first met him but i've also seen that
they cast a child
actor to play him at a younger age and
we don't know anything else about that
it'll be interesting to see how this all
ties into the ending and i suppose this
would be a good place to end the video
let me know what you think in the
comments and please like this video if
you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already i'll be doing more dark
videos weekly until season 3 is released
thanks for watching i will talk to you
soon